ladies and gentlemen the world famous
little Sebastian what yes oh my God
I never thought I'd get to meet him it's
really him well done Leslie well done
little Sebastian made his debut at the
last Harvest Festival in 1987 and he was
an instant phenomenon for the next few
years Sebastian was the number one boy's
name in Pawnee and the number three
girl's name so what am I missing what's
the deal with this Pony he's not a pony
man he's a mini horse there's a big
difference well then why is he so famous
does he do something what does he do son
this horse has an honorary degree from
Notre Dame we all need to be very
careful okay remember this little guy's
25 now and he has cataracts in both eyes
he has severe arthritis Jerry's gonna
look after him yes I am we are both on
the same diabetes medication are you my
glue control buddy are you
isn't it amazing yeah I just got to be
honest I don't know what the big deal is
get out you got Tilda yeah oh we got you
but the real coup is over there
little Sebastian
you
kidding me you got little Sebastian see
for yourself oh wow he is so adorable
it's a good boy Jerry stop bothering
little Sebastian Leslie said I should
watch him for a little bit perfect I've
gotta go get him a Tails crunchy
most people look at little Sebastian and
they see a famous mini horse I see an
advertising opportunity for my club the
snakehold lounge wow that is a
shockingly huge mini horse erection
what about your friend Ben
Story one of
one of you know when I was an 18 year
old mayor I tried to build a winter
sports complex called ice town and it
bankrupted the city I was also
shortstopping my JV baseball team no one
ever brings that up and now you're
involved with this do I smell another
disaster hopefully look John this
Festival thanks to the tireless efforts
of Leslie Knope it's going to bring
people nothing but happiness not even I
could screw that up I'm a recorder not
your therapist
so anytime someone takes a picture of
them the snakehold's logo is in it am I
a genius or what hey Tom where's little
Sebastian
uh somebody let the gate open and he got
out Jerry
what are you talking about unbelievable
another in a long string of miserable
failures you lost little Sebastian I
wasn't even here exactly you look for
him I gotta go tell everyone what you
did
he gave us a scare but he's back now the
one the only Lil Sebastian
thank you
[Music]
we spotted him from the top of the
ferris wheel at the center of the corn
maze
after the power came back on we went and
got him it took us four hours to solve
that maze took the horse 15 minutes
Jerry's still out there
I suppose I ought to go look for him
right after I get a bratwurst
you're the best ever he's a close second
aren't you a little Sebastian
really is amazing you finally get it now
right
hello
he's fantastic I totally get it now
I don't get it at all it's kind of a
small horse I mean what am I missing am
I crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah no I totally heard that it was
great
I have some very important news about
our favorite mini horse little Sebastian
he died last night no
but we can take comfort in the fact that
he's in heaven now doing the two things
he loves doing the most eating carrots
and urinating freely when I walked in
this morning and saw the flag was at
half mast I thought
all right another bureaucrat ate it
but then I found out it was a little
Sebastian
half-mast is too high
show some damned respect because of all
he's done for the town we are going to
be holding a small memorial service for
him but for now I think we should bow
our heads in a moment of silence
the best day
[Music]
I got it thank you now we have a special
presentation courtesy of the folks at
entertainment 720. I hope you brought a
change of clothes because your eyes are
about to piss tears
you're nasty
[Music]
foreign
who are we
where are we going in life
what is the meaning of all of this
these are questions little Sebastian
never had to answer because he was a
horse
instead he just brought us joy and
happiness and isn't that the point you
got to join the company I'm the bank but
you're the money I know Jay but it'd be
a big leap and I will take that leap
with you I'm Thelma you're Louise
can't die full of regret once you live
your life like that cow from the video
he was a horse yeah because he followed
his dreams
there was no obstacle too large
no mountain too high
no Valley too low
Sebastian had a long life
filled with wonder
good night little Sebastian
forever
[Applause]
I love this town so much and I'm just so
proud to live here
and we're gonna close tonight out with a
tribute to pawnee's greatest treasure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
ladies and gentlemen Mr Duke Silva
[Applause]
[Music]
e
you
to
listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]